one of my friends
his wife's sister is six foot two
without heels very tall wife's sister
wife sisters true jordy's sisters
okay go on go on uh she was walking
through a supermarket and she was uh
lamenting the fact that she can't find a
partner that is taller than her like
women on average want to date someone at
least that's not shorter yeah right and
uh she's struggling and they're walking
around the supermarket and they see this
guy he's like six foot seven of the
first side apparently really good
looking dude and she sees him on the
edge of the aisle she's like oh wow sort
of nudges the sister and says like I
might go go and speak to him and then
they see him push the trolley along as
they follow him around the Isle like
stalkers and they see him go up to a
five foot three goal who pops something
in the cart and like gives him a kiss on
the cheek and keeps on going and she's
like this short
she could have had five five she could
have had five six she could have had
five she could have had five four and it
would have been fine me meanwhile
six foot two can't find any Partners out
there and she's taking him up yeah is it
the case that girls that earn 30 grand a
year shouldn't be going for millionaires
for precisely the same reason this tall
girl problem they're capturing if you're
a PhD that earns half a million year as
a woman like you don't get a broker dude
precisely so should it be the case that
it's like you should have a height limit
so that it makes it fairer for the
dating world what do you think that is
kind of interesting women are allowed to
have standards
yeah
we're not really allowed to have that
how so it seems like there's more
scrutiny when we want standards but
women are allowed to have standards like
they they can date someone who they can
say I don't want to date someone who
makes less money than me and I do want
to date someone who is taller than me
and I want to date again all these
specific things and that's okay and when
we do that we're objectifying them in
some way I think that that's unfair
that's probably unfair but if they're
tapping into their biological impulses I
guess that's okay I guess the question
is when can we stop tapping into our
biological impulses well the equivalent
for men is that mandate younger
that is true so this is one thing that
the management that's what that has to
do with like uh fertility youth Etc
specifically right yeah well utilizing
fertility yeah but what is resources and
status for that's protection of your
baby that's why women tend to date up
and across yeah dominant dominance and
height in the men so like this is one of
the things that never really gets
discussed in the world of online men's
advice for dating yeah they'll always
point to women and say your hypergamy is
[ __ ] disgusting
um why is it that you want the
millionaire you don't realize that
you're a five out of ten and actually
you're trying to get like these guys
that is yeah 0.1 of the entire
population yeah and you go okay has any
guy ever been told that they should date
older yeah because you're saying women
your inbuilt predisposition is wrong
yeah maybe that's Up For Debate but if
you're going to make that case you have
to say to men your preference for
younger women is also wrong yeah yeah
100 yeah I think that makes and it's not
like we have a preference for younger
women always you just have a preference
for younger women as you get older
because that's where the fertility
um what would you say like it ranges
window yeah yeah window fertility unless
you need Leonardo DiCaprio exactly well
he's not even trying to get him pregnant
just bouncing off the [ __ ] limit of
25 yeah yeah [ __ ] 25th birthday and
there's like a [ __ ] scheduled email
there's a scheduled email on her
birthday as soon as you get to the right
time it is like I mean she's excited if
your girlfriend number eight yeah and
it's your 25th birthday and you know
that it's happened seven times before
you're like I saw this coming yeah I
don't know I think if a woman
if a woman wants to have kids and she
doesn't prioritize a man's wealth in
some way when she's picking him she
doesn't care enough about her kids
because resources will give the kids a
better life not only better life like
security while she is unable to work
like bare minimum like if you have a job
that's going to give you [ __ ] nine
months of whatever it's called maternity
leave Etc okay then you can have a
little bit more security but I don't
think there's anything wrong with a
woman going okay I need some protection
what if I want to raise these kids what
if I want to give these kids the best
possible I don't think there's anything
wrong I wouldn't call it Golding it's
gold digging if you want a rich guy and
don't want kids then you're a gold
digging [ __ ] if you want 20 kids get a
rich [ __ ] that can afford them
that's beautiful the only thing that
makes you a gold digger is not wanting
kids
because once you have kids ideally your
focus should be on them it's not even
the things that you're gonna get the
your focus should leave you I don't have
kids yet but I want kids like my wife
and I are trying to have kids and I'm
excited for this part of my life where
it's not only about me or my wife
anymore it's about something else I'm
excited to live for something else
that's great
but yeah I don't think you're a gold
dang woman if you if you have kids at
all the problem that you have is most
women want to date someone that earns
the same or more than them I don't think
anyone wants to date this the same they
want to date more right at the very
least yeah it would be except the same
yes but they would want more yeah the
issue is that women are out earning men
two to one women completing four-year
U.S college degrees women between 21 and
29 and 1 111 pounds more than men do so
you have an ever increasing group of
women that are high performing but
that's date by the way uh-huh not just
[ __ ] [ __ ] is totally different but
you're going to have to get past [ __ ] in
order to get to date for the most part
that's if a dude wants to here's the
thing where I think there's this like
all these things are true but I think
the argument starts to fall apart a bit
of it because
the dudes that are incredibly frustrated
by women aren't trying to date and have
a girlfriend they're trying to get some
[ __ ] correct so and girls will give you
some [ __ ] even if you don't have a good
job and all this other stuff please
believe I got way I got plenty of [ __ ]
before I did anything right now I know
there's dudes right now that are and I
was joking around this on the podcast
but like if you ever want to be
complimented by a dude just tell them
you got [ __ ] before you were famous and
they're gonna tell you everything about
you why you got [ __ ] oh your handsome
your jaw you're in good shape all this
other [ __ ] not not your personality at
all that you they become the biggest
objectifier of you because they're
trying to they're trying to tell
themselves why they don't get [ __ ]
right so but 100 you can't girls are
willing to sleep with dudes that are
making that make them feel comfortable
safe and also laugh and enjoy and have a
good time obviously lifestyle helps
there's tons of dudes getting [ __ ]
because they got yachts and all this
other [ __ ] but uh you do not need that I
promise you do not need that at all to
get laid that is the biggest lie ever at
all
at all it's easier but you do not need
it I was living with my parents for
years bringing girls into their
apartment my mom drinking a [ __ ] 40
of Coors Light I mean it's crazy I don't
know why she would drink that Scottish
women shout this guy's one and then just
saying hello and like being an adult
late 20s
living with my parents crushing
they don't care so do you think there's
always talk on the internet but be fun
that's what they care about there are so
few guys that are fun
that is the rarest thing in the world a
guy who's genuinely fun well think about
one of the things that the current
dating advice would make people do make
them take their lives very seriously who
would make them take dating incredibly
seriously the interactions every
interaction you're thinking is that this
person trying to take advantage of me do
I need to set the tone here do I need to
just have some [ __ ] fun laugh be
silly they will also be silly you'll
have a great [ __ ] time she might have
these requirements and eventually go you
know what this person isn't taking his
life uh I don't want to say seriously
but this person isn't at a place in
their life where I can move forward with
this but please believe you go to a city
like New York City where there's so many
women are just moving here they actually
are looking to hook up with God they're
like I want to hook up with my first guy
in New York oh I've never hooked up with
a Puerto Rican guy this is going to be
really fun they're going to be
objectifying you they got I've never
hooked up with a bartender from a thing
boom done I it is like the biggest myth
ever is that these girls do not want to
[ __ ] guys they do and they don't give a
[ __ ] what your value is what is your
value that night are you the funny guy
at the bar that night you're the highest
value made
simple as that I think you that you have
to almost lie to yourself a little bit
more
you have to you should lie to yourself
be like every girl in here is starved
for dick
and unfortunately I only have one but
that's the the mentality that you should
enter the room with I really do believe
that I think that would help you not to
mentality every woman in here is trying
to take my gold yeah
what a horrible way to live in other
news this episode is brought to you by
whoop it is the best fitness tracker
that I have ever found it's the only one
that I've ever stuck with and it tracks
absolutely everything from my sleep to
my recovery even the workouts that I do
every single day through this strap
which is on 24 7. my resting heart rate
my heart rate variability and even how
much I'm breathing throughout the night
tells me my quality of sleep it gives me
trends and reports over time but the
most important thing is it actually
nudges my behavior through suggestions
in an app it's a digital coach not just
a fitness tracker and it encourages me
to change my behavior that will improve
my health over the long term even better
than that you can join for free pay
nothing for the brand new whoop 4.0
strap and get your first month for free
so you buy it for free try it for free
and if you do not like it after 29 days
they'll give you your money back head to
join.woop.com Modern wisdom to sign up
right now that's join.woop.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]